téva 20h avec roger gicquel lefranc
vendues à l'arabie saoudite va devenir
hôtel flottant sans doute en floride
vingt commerçants à la table du
président de la république
au menu tva et retraite la catalogne à
son nouveau président josep tarradellas
ce sucre 75 pays demande à la france de
diminuer sa production
les professionnels refusent la perte
serait de 3 milliards de francs
bonsoir non décidément la nostalgie
n'est plus ce qu'elle était le france
c'est fini pour la france
le france et vendues on a déjà tellement
pleuré dessus dans les chaumières en
paroles et en chansons qu'aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt le soulagement
c'est le secrétaire d'état aux
transports qui a parlé tout à l'heure
d'une certaine nostalgie parce que nous
allons voir partir le france mais il
faut se faire une raison
on ne pouvait plus entretenir cette
princesse le dernier de nos
transatlantique condamné au désarmement
il ya trois ans par le prix du pétrole
et puis a ajouté comme pour s'excuser
monsieur cavaillé ça ne veut pas dire
que c'est la fin des croisières pourvu
que les bateaux soit adapté aux moyens
de l'économie ce qui n'empêche pas les
syndicats aujourd'hui de s'inquiéter
pour d'autres paquebot lefranc qui ne
sera pas rebaptiser a été racheté par
une compagnie internationale dirigée par
un des plus puissants hommes d'affaires
saoudiens
monsieur à crâne rouge est en relation
constante avec notre pays monsieur auger
est considéré comme l'un des meilleurs
amis de la france en arabie depuis
trente ans rappelle la compagnie
générale maritime et il veut monsieur
auger que le paquebot continue à être
l'instrument du prestige français ils
pourraient être reconvertis en palaces
flottants en centres d'exposition
mouillé au large des états unis du
québec ou du moyen-orient faire des
croisés des croisières bref il ya encore
beaucoup de points d'interrogation comme
vous le voyez notamment sur le prix de
vente entre 60 et 100 millions de francs
on dit 80 millions mais c'est vrai qu'il
a une grande capacité hôtelière lefranc
1000 chambres
restaurant pour trois mille couverts
plus les salles de spectacles piste de
danse piscine etc
le france restera encore quelques
semaines au havre le temps de le
remettre en état de naviguer c'est vrai
qu'on ne le reverra pas partir sans un
petit pincement au coeur mais nous
verrons avec emmanuel de la taille que
cette solution était inévitable pour
l'un des plus beaux vestiges d'une
époque révolue
écoutons d'abord les projets du nouveau
propriétaire france c'est un centre de
loisirs la vérité c'est un centre
français c'est la france et va continuer
à être là alors c'est là où il ya va
elle va avoir un hôtel avant tout et
l'hôtel j'espère il sera géré par une
société française
après il va avoir les restaurants qui
vont continuer parce que le france a été
toujours très réputée par la qualité de
ses de sa restauration
et puis je vais à grandir en plus le
côté des boutiques pour donner n'est ce
pas le plus possible la chance aux
commerçants français de vendre des
produits français
nous pensons à l'exploiter aux états
unis et probablement en floride gloire
et déboires que pouvait-on faire de
mieux avec le france triste réalité sous
peine de l'envoyer à la ferraille
il fallait le vendre au plus vite pour
arrêter les pertes le seul entretien de
sa pitoyable paralysie war coûté 10
millions par an et on aurait vite
dépensé plus que son prix de vente aux
alentours de 100 millions aujourd'hui
100 millions c'est aussi l'équivalent de
l'aide totale de l'état pour notre
dernier transatlantique constamment
déficitaires même s'il n'avait jamais
manqué d'amateurs fortune ces chiffres
implacables fondu france le meilleur
symbole de la fin de la belle époque de
l'énergie à bon marché et de la nouvelle
ère du pétrole cher les symptomatique
que seuls les riches séoudiens ait pu
s'offrir le luxe de racheter ce paquebot
de prestige immédiatement coulé par la
tempête du cac triplement du prix du
carburant
malgré son dernier tour du monde des
milliardaires ce monstre sacré avaient
brûlé en 74 un déficit de 200 millions
la somme à la
il est maintenant vendu c'était le
naufrage finances la condamnation pour
train de vie ruines du franc se mettent
alors la fureur et les projets de
sauvetage les plus fous universités ou
maisons de retraite qui n'avait comme
point commun qu'une subvention sans fin
par l'état de ce musée du souvenir des
paquebots de rêve en fait de l'amérique
au moyen-orient n'a étudié une
cinquantaine de propositions sérieuses
qui balançaient entre trois solutions
la reconversion en marchandise aussi peu
réaliste que la transformation d'une
rolls en camionnette
les croisières type super milliardaire
au pèlerinage à la mecque qui se sont
révélés hors de prix et finalement l'
hôtel flottant devant les palmiers de
floride ou du moyen-orient avec ses 1000
chambres au célèbre restaurant de trois
mille couverts son équipement
parfaitement conservés lefranc réaménagé
mais immobilisé pourrait encore prolongé
l'image d'une france de luxe et nous
servir à conquérir des marchés pour une
france industrielle en crise qui se
sépare avec nostalgie de ce signe
extérieur de ce plan d' noter tout de
même qu'il y à déjà une opposition sur
la vente du france mais il m'étonnerait
qu'elle aille bien loin un seuil
un saoudien ayant acheté le france voilà
qu'un israélien le revendique c'est le
député sam elle flatte o'keefe ou qui
fut poursuivie pour escroquerie en
france et qui dans son pays ne jouit pas
de la meilleure réputation depuis la
campagne électorale qui a prêté le flanc
pour lui au plus gros soupçon il affirme
aujourd'hui qu'il offre et de 35 pour
cent de plus pour le france et qu'il a
chargé son avocat en france de faire
opposition à la vente
et il ajoute si c'est comme ça je
n'acheterai pas le paquebot renaissance
affaire à suivre pour voir si ce sont
des propos en l'air ou si c'est plus
sérieux
l'état doit - intervenir dans les
affaires des commerçants
vive la liberté du commerce mais entre
la liberté et l'intervention de l'état
c'est une question de dosage c'est ce
qu'auront sans doute retenu les vingt
commerçants et prestataires de services
qui étaient les hôtes les autres à
déjeuner du président de la république
déjeuner de travail qui fait suite
d'ailleurs à celui de juin dernier avec
les chefs des petites et moyennes
entreprises
ce qu'on cherche c'est à aborder dans le
concret les difficultés qui se posent à
cette profession pas toujours de tout
repos il est vrai aujourd'hui les
différents commerces étaient
représentées bouchers coiffeurs
transporteurs routiers etc
daniel duigou les a rencontrés
il en a profité pour faire le point sur
cette profession qui a tout de même su
se moderniser depuis 20 ans ce qui a
d'ailleurs ne l'oublions pas créer des
drames chez ceux qui ne pouvaient pas
suivre cette évolution le déjeuner des
commerçants à l'elysée où on pouvait
apporter ces problèmes daniel duigou
madame comment s'est déroulé ce repas
très bien très simplement et très
librement nous avons tous pu nous
exprimer et durs ce qui concernait nos
professions j'étais à côté du président
ce qu'est ce qui vous a le plus frappé
pendant ce repas bien c'est la
courtoisie du débat c'est à dire on
s'est exprimée très franchement j'ai
retenu d'abord que le président de la
république était excessivement attentif
à tous les problèmes qu'on lui exposer
ça n'est pas une je crois que ce n'est
pas une façade
monsieur quel est le problème que vous
avez abordé eh bien ce sont les
problèmes de l'emploi en particulier
dans les temps les entreprises de
prestation de services
car nous sommes à peu près convaincu de
pouvoir offrir plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'emplois mais actuellement le
coût du salaire le coût des charges
sociales et elle dans une politique de
blocage des prix que nous ne pouvons pas
rémunéré comme il le faudrait les gens
qui vont chez nous et qu'il y a donc
peut être à considérer autrement
maintenant les charges sociales de ceux
qui font de la main d'oeuvre qui vendent
de la main d'oeuvre
comparativement aux charges sociales qui
sont peut-être celle des entreprises
industrielles ou la part de manoeuvre
est excessivement réduite minimes
si l'on regarde globalement la situation
du commerce et des services
on constate que c'est un des secteurs
économiques qui a le moins souffert de
la crise ce qui d'ailleurs ne veut pas
dire qu'il n'y a pas eu de catastrophe
dans certains cas plus importants le
commerce et les services ont rattrapé le
retard qu'ils avaient pris par rapport à
l'industrie depuis 20 ans un atout donc
un atout pour l'avenir qui n'a pas été
obtenue sans effort et parfois même sans
sacrifice un atout qui a eu comme point
de départ la loi d'orientation appelé
également loi croyez cette loi avait un
double enjeu un enjeu économique le
commerce et de l'activité charnière
entre la production et les consommateurs
et puis un enjeu politique
le commerce est un électorat qu'aucun
gouvernement ne veut ou voudraient se
mettre à dos
il existait une épouvantable variété de
difficultés qui conditionnait plus ou
moins la survie de ces métiers de
commerce et des services
on pouvait les classer en trois volets
d'abord le volet fiscal ne plus être
considéré comme un fraudeur
professionnels le volet social obtenir
les mêmes protections qu'un salarié
enfin le volet économique assurer un
arbitrage entre les commerçants et les
grandes surfaces
sur ces trois fronts d'importantes
batailles ont été gagnés le gouvernement
en profite pour tirer un bilan positif
de son action tandis que les
organisations professionnelles
elle estime que d'autres batailles sont
encore à gagner la politique la gauche
d'un côté chez les communistes
l'accumulation des preuves du virage à
droite du parti socialiste
de l'autre chez les socialistes une
défense qui consiste à dire qu'on lui
fait de faux procès avec ce trait
d'humour de pierre mauroy
ce sont les socialistes qui sont en
ligne droite tandis que les communistes
vous font un virage en marche arrière
le radical de gauche robert fabre est
critiqué par le socialiste georges sarre
pour avoir évoqué la gêne aux entorses
aux entournures qui avaient constitué
qu'avait constitué le programme commun
et pour avoir dit aussi que la gauche
pour pour la gauche il était mieux
d'aller séparément la bataille
électorale le temps du rapprochement
semblait loin loin d'être arrivé patrice
duhamel
oui il apparaît aujourd'hui que l'on
s'achemine vraiment vers cette rupture
qui semblait probable déjà au lendemain
de la suspension des négociations sur
l'actualisation du programme commun il y
avait eu la période du dialogue de sourd
puis celle des attaques indirectes puis
celle des conflits ouverts
on en est maintenant à la mise en cause
permanente au point que les anciens
partenaires ne sont même plus des alliés
et deviennent de plus en plus des
adversaires
les exemples sont nombreux et le dernier
en date très révélateur pendant le
week-end se déroulait à versailles la
convention pour l'europe
au nombre des participants raymond barre
beaucoup de leaders de la majorité et le
socialiste pierre mauroy immédiatement
le parti communiste réagi c'est une peu
une preuve flagrante du virage à droite
du ps déclare roland leroy l'humanité
évoque dans son éditorial le concert de
versailles et laisse entendre que le
parti socialiste est prêt à gérer la
crise dans le cadre d'une europe
supranationale
réponse immédiate de pierre mauroy c'est
un faux procès je me suis exprimé à
versailles comme un européen socialiste
la lettre de l'inité répond point par
point aux accusations communiste et puis
nous venons de l'apprendre françois
mitterrand vient de déclarer je ne sais
pas s'il vaut mieux affirmer les
positions européennes du parti
socialiste dans une assemblée où se
trouvaient des formations de la majorité
où aller déjeuner à l'elysée comme
certains députés communistes l'ont fait
ajoutons à cet échange d'amabilités un
éditorial de l'hebdomadaire communiste
france nouvelle selon lequel il ya
convergence entre la grande bourgeoisie
et le parti socialiste ajoute au encore
une tentative d'appel à l'union
d'intellectuels socialistes et
communistes a échoué après que certains
communistes et renoncer à apporter leurs
signatures au total on ne peut que
constater une aggravation sensible de la
crise on voit mal comment après ce tir
de barrage réciproque pc et ps pourrait
encore se réconcilier en continuant
ainsi de se tourner le dos
les deux parties sont peut-être tout
simplement en train de tirer un trait
sur ce qui fut l'union de la gauche
oui décidément je le répète souvent
l'espagne continue à bouger
en attendant la prochaine réunion des
partis de l'union nationale demain sans
doute pour mettre en oeuvre un programme
économique social et politique concertée
et après une manifestation monstre
vendredi soir à madrid où des dizaines
de milliers de partisans de la droite en
traiter le premier ministre de traître
ce dernier monsieur suares assisté
aujourd'hui à barcelone à l'entrée en
fonctions de monsieur tarradellas ce
président de la généralité de catalogne
immense changement
salvepar 250000 personnes qui ont
accueilli hier le retour de monsieur
tarradellas ce qui vivait en exil en
france depuis la fin de la guerre civile
jack junior du moulin le premier
ministre espagnol monsieur suarez a
assisté aujourd'hui à la prestation de
serment du président de la générale noté
me sankara des lances dans ce même
palais du vieux barcelone et masia
proclamait en 1931 le gouvernement
provisoire catalan
un ancien ministre président compagnie
si la république
ce stade est là c'est revenu hier après
quelque 38 ans d'exil dans la capitale
catalane où une foule de 250 mille
personnes a célébré avec lui devant le
palais de monjuich l'autonomie catalane
retrouver une autonomie que monsieur
tarradellas c'est les chefs des
principaux partis catalans élu le 15
juin dernier ont négocié non sans mal
avec le gouvernement madre et qui doit
être maintenant mise en place pour le
sait aux termes des accords conclus la
catalogne aura son propre gouvernement
le conseil exécutif et ce sera même le
seul gouvernement de concentration en
europe avec notamment les socialistes et
communistes et les centristes
mais monsieur tarradellas ce ne paraît
pas trop pressé de le constituer ce
gouvernement du moins tant que le
transfert effectif des pouvoirs de madre
à la généralité n'aura pas été effectuée
la question qui se pose désormais est de
savoir si les forces politiques catalan
de toutes tendances qui sont restés unis
depuis juin dernier dans la perspective
de ce compromis historique continueront
de l'être sous l'autorité de monsieur
tarradellas
il faut empêcher que le terrorisme
n'entame le sens de la démocratie les
citoyens a demandé helmut schmidt aux
syndicalistes du monde entier
aujourd'hui demain auront lieu à
stuttgart des obsèques nationales de
hans martin flyers mais l'allemagne
encore sous le coup des émotions des
actes terroristes qu'elle a vécu en
apprend toujours tous les jours sur la
bande à baader les conditions de leur
détention et leur suicide en prison
tous les jours on trouve quelque chose
dans la cellule de bader et de ses
complices plastique arm9 matériel de
radio si on trouvait un hélicoptère en
pièces détachées dans le plafond sous
plancher on ne serait pas plus étonné
pendant ce temps la rescapée des
suicides in gare muller affirme qu'elle
ne se souvient de rien n'a pas voulu
attenter à ses jours dit elle faisons le
point avec bernard wolker et ensuite
avec robert pietri l'inventaire dans les
cellules
on attendait avec intérêt les
révélations ou le témoignage des young
heart malheur des hommes gardent le leur
et cette jeune fille qui s'est suicidé
dans sa cellule dans la nuit de mardi en
compagnie de bader race peu et hunt line
mais alors que bader et race fut avait
choisi une arme à feu et hunt line
s'était pendu et en garde mme haller
s'était porté plusieurs coups de couteau
d'un couteau à pain dans la poitrine
elle a survécu et elle a reçu samedi son
avocate d'après cette dernière sa
cliente ne se souvient maintenant de
rien elle s'est évanoui subitement au
milieu de la nuit et ne s'est réveillé
qu'allonger dans une civière dans le
couloir de la prison elle à ce moment-là
entendu dire que batteur heras pneus
étaient morts les autorités allemandes
s'attendait à ce genre de déclarations
et en garde me leur dit on ici ne
contredira certainement pas ses
camarades morts qui ont voulu faire
croire qu'ils ont été assassinés la
chasse aux terroristes n'a encore donné
ce soir aucun résultat elle se poursuit
avec une grande intensité dans toute
l'allemagne
la police a reçu plus de 15000
renseignements de la population et
commence maintenant aller vérifier un
par un la coopération avec la police
française fonctionne très bien dit on à
bonnes les obsèques de monsieur flyers
seront célébrées demain matin à 10h30
dans le centre de stuttgart en l'église
eberhardt le président de la république
fédérale monsieur celle rendra hommage
au président du patronat en présence du
gouvernement et de tous les hommes
importants de l'économie allemande
la sécurité des personnalités sera
assurée par les hommes du fameux
commando gsg9 qui libéra à mogadiscio
des otages dans l'avion de la lufthansa
andreas baader et ses amis seront inhumé
jeudi dans un autre cimetière de
stuttgart
une polémique a éclaté à ce sujet
certains trouvant qu'il était indécent
que les trois terroristes soient
enterrées côte à côte à proximité
d'allemands illustre et de victimes du
nazisme ont fini aujourd'hui de creuser
la tombe de madère et de ses amis et les
autorités de stuttgart ne voit pas sans
appréhension
approché le jour de l'inhumation la
morgue où ont été déposés les corps du
bader et de ses amis a déjà été maculées
d'inscriptions vengeresse
l'inventaire des objets trouvés dans les
cellules des différents terroriste n'est
pas facile à faire
voyons cela en détail mais auparavant
voici un schéma de la prison un long
couloir de 15 mètres avec au bout une
vitre à l'épreuve des balles derrière
cette vitre des gardiens qui observe les
allées et venues par un circuit de
caméras de télévision un circuit
intérieur
ici un accès à la salle de gymnastique
et au parloir et au dessus un vaste
chrome noir alors le détail de
l'inventaire dans la cellule d'andreas
baader
on a trouvé un revolver 6 35 et 20
balles dans son électrophone des lames
de rasoir un pain de plastic et une
sonde gastrique sous le lavabo
elle aurait pu servir de garos dans la
cellule de yann carl raspe et on a
trouvé un pistolet 9 mm et 20 cartouches
dans un trou du mur car les murs sont
présents siens un transistor un
manipulateur de maurs et une pile dans
une cache
en face chez hans line on trouve des
écouteurs à côté chez mademoiselle mot
l'heure la seule rescapée
on a trouvé un couteau de cuisine et
puis ici dans une cellule qui était vide
maintenant mais qui avait été occupé par
paul on a découvert du câble électrique
300 grammes d'explosifs et des prises
dans un paquet de café
les détenus étaient fouillés depuis des
mois par les mêmes gardiens il est
possible que ces gardiens et été acheté
ou menacé il aurait donc servi de
passeurs on les écoute en ce moment ils
sont en environ une dizaine les
terroristes qui étaient en haute
surveillance avant l'enlèvement de
schleier jouissait auparavant de régime
fort libéral il avait des relations
entre eux et on déclare que bader était
souvent dans la cellule de hunt line
il avait un poste de télévision toujours
dans cette cellule de bader un
électrophone un transistor des livres
est une machine à écrire et puis surtout
il recevait quotidiennement la visite de
leurs amis et de leurs avocats alors la
prison la plus chère d'allemagne était
peut-être aussi la plus ouverte
d'allemagne alors revenons à l'anc est
maintenant le très important travail de
recherche et de renseignements effectué
par le comici le commissaire
divisionnaire rorschach de strasbourg a
permis d'établir en quelques jours
seulement les mouvements de 11 des 16
terroristes de la bande à baader
l'hypothèse d'une fuite des terroristes
par la suisse se renforce
les recherches intensives s'intensifie
tout au long de cette région que l'on
rappelle
que l'on appelle celle des trois
frontières certains se demandent comment
des terroristes ont pu passer en suisse
par exemple sans se faire remarquer mais
c'est une frontière verte plus floue
contre le plan ce qu'on ne pense avec
des vallons et des forêts et on en parle
comme de la frontières passoires aussi
la police et les gendarmes ont passé la
région au peigne fin spécialement les
ancien blockhaus de la ligne maginot
nombre dans la région
et pourtant et pourtant une équipe de
tf1 avec jean-louis burgat a fait
l'expérience de cette frontières
passoires ans ni stationnant une heure
et demie sans s'y faire remarquer malgré
une police qu on dit partout présentes
regardez voici la région des trois
frontières à droite l'allemagne à gauche
la france en bas la suisse notre
itinéraire mulhouse altkirch rappelle
villers essai de la sortie de linsdorf
que nous avons sans problème trouver
notre route
problème nous quittons la route de bâle
direction leimen 300 mètres plus loin
nous avons deux noms la départementale
numéro 9
pour la 9 bis qui va vers la frontière
et qui est parfaitement indiquée sur la
carte 500 m de campagne la forêt et puis
nous découvrons cette pancarte frontière
suisse attention défense de passer son
contrôle c'est écrit uniquement en
allemand pas de douane pas de police
nous traversons la forêt pour déboucher
dans cette petite vallée au fond le
village suisse de rôdeur stuff monsieur
nous venons de franchir une forêt
nous sommes passés en suisse nous sommes
ensuite 6 6 7 6 c'est à dire que la
france est à combien de distance 10 6
500 m quoi en suisse sans être contrôlé
nous visitons les villages de rodersdorf
mnc rienne retour vers la france par un
autre itinéraire et la seconde surprise
le poste frontière fond c'est évident
jusqu'à mulhouse nous ne verrons aucun
policier l'étang curieux que nous avons
cette année les saisons fantaisiste le
beau temps qui rate ses rendez vous et
qui vient quand on ne l'attend pas tout
ça a des conséquences variables sur la
production agricole
si nous avons manqué de fruits et si
notre balance commerciale a souffert
d'importations massives
le phénomène est inversée pour la pomme
de terre et pour le sucre les betteraves
que l'on a récolté actuellement nous
garantissent notre consommation
intérieure pendant plus de deux ans en
comprend les pressions d'autres pays qui
veulent amener nos producteurs à
diminuer leur surface de plantation me
dit jean françois robin est le sucre
français pèse lourd sur le marché
mondial où ils concurrencent la canne à
sucre
mais pour la france le sucre c'est une
rentrée de 3 milliards en devises chaque
année et ça compte
jean françois robin est
traditionnellement positive notre
balance extérieure agroalimentaire
accusé un déficit de 2 milliards 700
millions au 1er septembre
dans ces conditions comment renoncer un
atout tels que le sucre
le chiffre d'affaires est en année
normale de 7 milliards de francs dont 3
milliards à l'exportation cette année 77
sans être exceptionnel doit être très
bonne on prévoit une production de 4
millions 50 mille tonnes pour une
consommation de 2 millions de tonnes
juste retour des choses pour les
planteurs après la faible récolte de la
dernière une betterave qui pèse environ
un kilo rien à voir avec celle de
l'année dernière
un kilo de betterave est bien cela doit
donner avec la richesse de cette année
environ 130 g de sucre c'est bon c'est
très bon c'est certainement une des
meilleures récoltes que nous ayons
connue alors que l'année dernière
c'était la plus mauvaise récolte alors
est ce que ça veut dire que cette année
les betteraviers vont gagner beaucoup
d'argent alors ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant que les betteraviers vont gagner
beaucoup d'argent ne faut pas minimiser
ils vont faire une bonne récolte ils
vont gagner de l'argent
pas beaucoup d'argent parce que nous
sommes payés selon le quota que nous
avons et les prix sont différents selon
les quotas le quota c'est la quantité
maximum à produire mais comme on ne peut
savoir à l'avancé les rendements précis
le marché commun fixe trois quotas pour
chaque pays
le quota a correspond à la consommation
intérieure il est payé à un prix garanti
cette année 147 francs la tonne de
betteraves
la production supplémentaire est
répartie en côte ab pour une première
tranche payer 30% moins cher et en côte
assez payé 50 francs seulement la tonne
avec les rendements de cette année les
planteurs accuse un manque à gagner de
l'ordre de 1000 francs l'hectare cet
argent qui ne l'auraient pas donnée est
utilisé par la caisse européenne pour
chercher de nouveaux débouchés ou
constituer un stock comme cela vient
d'être décidée à genève à la demande des
américains qui se souviennent de la
pénurie de 1970 c'est environ un
milliard de francs que les planteurs
français abandonne ainsi pour participer
eux-mêmes offrait d'écoulement de leurs
excédents plutôt que de diminuer la
production
nous continuons à faire des betteraves
pourquoi parce que d'une part nous avons
nous sommes organisés pour avoir une
production importante
nous avons une main d'oeuvre en
conséquence et il faut penser aussi élan
les chicots rit on emploie en campagne
environ vingt mille personnes
la france estime aussi qu allah sa place
sur le marché mondial déficitaire elle
envisage des contrats avec les pays
arabes la russie voire la chine et elle
n'a nullement l'intention de renoncer à
une rentrée de 3 milliards de francs de
devises on ne jettera pas le surplus de
betteraves à la décharge publique mais
on l'a fait pour les choux fleurs en
bretagne 2 millions de têtes ont été
détruites en quelques jours et c'est
aussi une conséquence du temps clément
les choux-fleurs mûrissent trop vite
et cette année on en a planté davantage
l'an dernier les choux-fleurs avait
souffert de la sécheresse
c'est tout dire sur les difficultés des
producteurs quand les anomalies de
saison se produise coup sur coup
bien sûr on comprend la nécessité de
soutenir les cours mais ces destructions
des fruits du travail et de la terre ça
fait toujours mal au coeur toujours au
chapitre du temps qu'il fait la décrue
s'est amorcée dans le sud est le gars a
baissé après 36 heures de rage
torrentielles la pluie a cessé
au milieu de la nuit dernière
le rhône dans le vaucluse à avignon la
côte d' alerte a été dans le rhône oui
la côte d'alerté a été largement dépassé
7 me mais là aussi c'est la décrue
depuis ce matin à midi presque partout
les cours d'eau avaient pratiquement
regagner leur lit la décrue a été aussi
rapide que la crue d'autant qu'il a
cessé de pleuvoir ou ça n'avait rien de
comparable avec pierre demain quand il
pleuvra ce sera faiblement et
passagèrement du massif central aux
frontières du nord et du nord-est belles
éclaircies attendus sur l'ouest le nord
ouest et le nord le matin attention au
brouillard assez dense dans le sud ouest
le centre et l'est température comme
aujourd'hui
jean claude narcy avec vous les autres
nouvelles de ce journal les socialistes
démocrates c'est à dire ceux qui ont
refusé dès le départ l'union de la
gauche ont réaffirmé aujourd'hui leur
volonté d'orienter le futur parlement
plus à gauche mais sans les communistes
leur secrétaire général eric hintermann
a annoncé qu'il se cuit qu'il
présenterait son parti 250 candidats aux
législatives
2500 salariés de la société d'aidé la
syrie de pompey en meurthe et moselle
seront au chômage technique du 6 au 13
novembre prochain
les raisons invoquées les stocks ont
dépassé six mille tonnes
depuis ce matin trois millions et demi
de parents d'élèves élisent leurs
représentants aux comités et des parents
des écoles maternelles et primaires
le vote va durer jusqu'au 10 novembre en
dehors des candidatures personnel quatre
fédérations présentent des listes et
demain à 13 heures dominique laurie dans
le journal du gourou zee animera un
débat avec jan cornet qui antoine
lagarde qui sont les deux présidents des
deux grandes fédérations élections
législatives
alice saunier séité secrétaire d'état
aux universités sera très probablement
candidate à metz dans la première
circonscription de la moselle et sous
l'étiquette majorité gérard nicoud été
réélu président du cidunati à l'occasion
du 9ème congrès de son syndicat
après l'attentât qui détruit qui a
détruit le relais hertzien de
pré-en-pail les émetteurs qui desservent
les régions bretagne et pays de loire
diffuse ce soir les émissions de tf1
les émetteurs qui dessert la région
normandie diffuse des émissions
d'antenne 2 et de fr3 notre part des
émissions fr3 qui ont été enregistrées à
paris ont été envoyés à rennes où elles
seront diffusées sur les régions
bretagne et pays de loire
les trois chaînes modulation de
fréquence radio fonctionne non
allemand les travaux de déblaiement du
centre de pré en pail se poursuivre
ainsi que l'étude des solutions de
dépannage mais il n'est pas encore
possible de donner des précisions sur la
date du rétablissement complet du
service de télévision jean lecanuet lui
demandent au gouvernement ce soir
quelles mesures il compte prendre pour
assurer à l'avenir la protection des
stations de retransmission de télévision
en chine le président akio feng a
convoqué pour le printemps prochain la
cinquième assemblée nationale populaire
c'est-à-dire le parlement chinois
une assemblée pas comme les autres car
il s'agira là d'entériner les réformes
entreprises entre autres une
augmentation générale des salaires
un effort de productivité de
modernisation enfin un retour à la
sélection dans l'enseignement supérieur
la sphère von opel semble prendre une
nouvelle tournure
l'été dernier les policiers avaient
saisi une tonne et demie de drogue dans
la propriété louée à saint tropez par
maria cristina von opel
la nièce du magna de l'industrie
automobile l'instruction se poursuit
mais en allemagne ont fait état d'un
possible lien entre cette affaire et des
trafiquants d'armes internationaux le
haschisch serait échanger régulièrement
contre les armes pour les combattants
chrétiens libanais et pour terminer ce
journal parlons un peu d'une passion qui
se répand dans le monde entier et pour
une fois les français ne sont pas en
retard
ils participent à ce mouvement de masse
qui marche et même qui court à côté du
progrès ils sont contre tout ce qui
piétinent
c'est l'armé des pieds et des mollets en
amérique ça s'appelle le ix ging le
jogging version moderne du footing ça
signifie qu'on court tout le temps comme
si on avait peur de l'immobilité et ça
se pratique en ville surtout à paris on
peut voir tous les jours des adeptes du
jogging qui s'ignorent sur le champ de
mars au bois de boulogne ou bois de
vincennes
on en voit aussi en province marche à
pied de 20 à 50 kilomètres souvent
organisées bientôt cross du figaro ou
courtes il est pourquoi courtil on
pourrait le demandé aussi aux new
yorkais aux cinq mille concurrents qui
viennent de participer un super marathon
où les professionnels et parmi eux
d'anciens champions olympiques cours est
aux côtés de simples mordus
regardez ces étonnantes images que
commente robert werner
qu'ils soient vendeurs de hot docs
dockers hommes d'affaires ou garçons
chargé de stocker les bouteilles de
whisky ici à new york ont fait du
jogging ou petit trot à n'importe quelle
heure le jour ou la nuit
envoûtés par ce sport certains
abandonnent leur métier pour s'y
consacrer
tel ce professeur qui a quitté
l'enseignement pour la course à pied
mais ce spectacle là on ne le voit pas
tous les jours c'est celui du marathon
qui vient de commencer
cinq mille concurrents parmi lesquels un
petit garçon de huit ans dans new york
désert et 500 mille spectateurs
beaucoup parmi ces coureurs pratique
d'habitude de jogging pour oublier la
montre et les gens pressés cette fois
mêlé à de vrais champions
ils ont voulu tout vulgairement eux
aussi battre des records et c'est bill
rodgers un américain de 29 ans qui a
gagné
il a mis deux heures 11 minutes et 20
secondes pour couvrir les 42 kilomètres
du marathon un français fernand kolbeck
s'est classé 7e
il est moniteur de sport des ptt de
strasbourg il a pensé très fort à la
cathédrale
mais cela ne l'a pas fait gagner et puis
je crois qu'il y avait aussi un petit
garçon de 8 ans qui a terminé la course
dernier journal jean pierre pernaut en
fin de soirée
je ne peux pas vous dire encore à quelle
heure bonne soirée à tous au nom de
toute l'équipe de tf1 actualité merci